attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
vous pourriez mettre votre main devant
votre bouche parce que je suis venu pour
un certificat j'ai pas envie de repartir
avec une angine alors mais moi je dis
cela c'est vache et j'ai un problème
j'ai pu estime bart
mais si je tousse et uniquement si
j'adore la clope en commun c'est pas
trop tôt ça fait 3 plomb qu'on attend et
j'ai fait une sieste après bouffer du
coup ça va décaler tous les rendez vous
de trois quarts d'heure
ah bon et genre ils ont besoin une
ordonnance ils vont entendre à nous
qu'est ce qui vous arrive
il faudrait un certificat médical pour
le sport si vous avez pris des bonnes
résolutions vous vous remettez au sport
vous avez acheté tout l'équipement et
vous allez gagner deux fois dans l'année
bingo voilà votre certificat et
vaumousse culte et pas avant
si vous y tenez pourquoi pas bon je sais
pas qui tu as payé 30 bal août on
vérifie que j'ai pas un truc qu'on
retire les 26 chefs non c'est bon si
vous prescrire de la vitamine d vous
trouvez que j'en ai besoin
non non je suis de mèche avec un labo
pharmaceutique si j'arrive à en écouler
sans boite je gagne un voyage aux
maldives les puceaux fera pas de mal
alors c'est pas vrai elle va bien alors
surtout ne touchez à rien avant que
j'arrive sur les lieux c'est quoi c'est
une urgence
ouais ce qu'ils sont en train
d'embarquer les bagnoles bougez pas je
reviens
en tout cas bravo parce que vous faites
vraiment un beau métier un sauver toutes
ces vies moi je souhaite des angines et
des gastros on sauve pas l'aiguillé avec
de l'aspirine
voilà votre ordonnance merci est sérieux
ou fait exprès mal écrits ou quoi
seulement ce pas contrôler ce que pour
faire chier les pharmaciens allez bonne
journée
ah bah non je vous sers pas la main non
non vous touchez des malades toute la
journée je dois pas choper une saloperie
moi je m'en fous je suis immunisé à
bientôt du coup
[Musique]